So in conjunction with our post-processing volume
parameters, we also have the ability
to add custom post-processing volume materials.
These materials can be added to the post-processing volume
via the post-processing materials input.
Now, we're not going to step through this class
on how to go create a custom robust post-processing
material.
However, there is one included.
So if I go down to our content drawer,
and within our materials custom folder,
there is this MPPV basic.
And if I open this up, I want to just show real quick
a couple of different things.
So the material creation process
itself is very straightforward.
Again, very much material 101, the difference
being that we will leverage some different nodes that
allow us to inject information within our post-process.
But things like these vector parameters
where we can expose them to be able to control them,
that, again, is all very much material 101.
As we saw with our localized fog volume,
in particular the material that we created for that,
we have some similar things that we
need to change as well for our post-processing material.
So if I select the main material output
itself or anywhere in the blank space of the graph,
the important thing to note here
is that we have to change our material domain to post-process.
And by doing this, you'll notice
that it removes a lot of our properties
and only allows for emissive color.
By changing the material domain, we're
now going to propagate information
into the post-processing domain
as it's going through all the different steps
to render the image.
So if you don't have that checked,
it's obviously not going to work,
so make sure your material is set to post-process.
And again, this is just a very basic example
I've created as a parent material.
If I go back down to our content drawer,
I've simply right-clicked Create Material Instance,
and now we have this MIPPV basic.
So this is the material that we're
going to apply in our post-processing volume.
All right, so with my post-processing volume
selected, and I do have my content drawer,
I have this selected as well.
So if I scroll down, I'm looking
for in the rendering features post-processing materials.
To add this material, simply click the little plus button,
which will add an element.
And in this case, we're going
to do an asset reference because we're
going to reference one of the assets in our content browser.
And I could do this little use selected asset
from content browser, and because it's selected,
it will apply, or you can select from the dropdown.
One pro tip that I do recommend
is as you're creating post-processing volume materials,
add something like a underscore PPV in your material,
because you notice the engine will show you
every material that is available,
which really all we want is those
that will be applied within the post-processing volume domain.
All right, let me scroll back down here.
So you can see that we do get this slider,
which essentially is just an opacity slider.
So this allows me to essentially fade
the actual material itself on top of our scene.
Let's just take a look real fast
at the material instance that I have here.
So I created a couple of vector parameters.
I'll just move this off here, color blend,
and then we also have this overlay base.
So if I just kind of reset some of these to white,
there we go.
So color overlay control,
which again is just like a granular opacity,
so we don't have to do within the material
or the post-processing material slot.
Color blend will be something that like goes
over the top of this, and of course our base.
So I could do something like green.
We'll use some very, very big colors here and hot pink.
And then we'll do something like this,
0.5 to blend between the two.
And you'll notice now kind of adjust.
Again, this is not a material that I would say
is something that would go into final production.
But the key here is that again,
by creating these materials
and injecting them in the post-processing,
we've got just additional control
outside of just the properties and parameters
that the post-processing volume affords us.
In the next video,
we'll walk through lighting an interior scene
from start to finish.